[Music]
Stowers watch it I left watch this
[Music]
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
[Music]
lightsaber Oh
[Music]
yeah
any
No
Galia one truth
[Music]
[Music]
oh uh yeah I don't really do this but uh
I just got I just got watch to get
really quick he got it so I can Star
Wars yeah I got it love that opening
shot it's like he's going to brutal
laughs rating or she seeing something
[Music]
I sure do see how like the
cinematography of this is already very
different computable and shot it right
Johnson shot like a Superman comes back
I get what that was the first time
[Music]
[ __ ] I must add a shot
when are those shift
and on lockers and we do one truth
[Music]
oh not yet cylinders do that pretty set
that
I only know one truth it's time for the
Jedi to end oh man
the emotional intensity just seems like
it's going to be amped up to a whole
other level in this one every shot they
showed here the characters just look so
intense
except for Finn who is like sleeping or
something in this tree I serve all the
shots of the Jove in the one jump issue
his eyes are closed I don't know what
he's doing I don't know if he added up
there's something bigger at Han and
everything that ship is like channeling
the forests or if he's just in a coma
being transferred watching the show the
second time there was definitely more I
caught it was like actually the subtle
of voiceover narrations I was hearing
when Ray's asked you know what you hear
and she was nice you here help me
obi-wan Kenobi and then when the show
Vader's mask II hear Vader breathing and
I think what you hear is seduced by the
dark side we could verb that before I
there is
by the donors yeah correct me if I'm
wrong I can't I wasn't able to tell that
Vader's mask or kylo ren's mask some of
you guys are good call me an idiot for
not knowing exactly which one I mean you
hear Vader's voice breathing over it and
then you hear obi-wan Kenobi's narration
so I'm assuming it's Vader's mask you
also hear the echoed Yoda saying train
you will why was it being said there
mandis like subtle touches of the
trigger
[Music]
versus the balance of like someone
saying a purchase and then something up
I can't quite make out kind of sounds
like Snoke then they're taking the audio
from my previous Star Wars movies and
putting it over this footage it really
looks like they're really tying it all
and they're wrapping it all and it's
good it's making me feel like this was
planned before they realized the Star
Wars movies with episode 7 I know
they're like inventing this now they
recently started inventing it but
looking at the footage and then here in
the audio it's making me feel like oh
this is all this is all supposed to
happen a long time ago people have been
speculating what a Star Wars the last
Jedi mean what did the last Jedi mean
and I wasn't expecting
Luke to be the one to be like I know the
truth the Jedi mess then for him to be
the one saying the Jedi should any that
you would think that's someone from the
dark side who wants the Jedi to end but
this is Luke Skywalker it's making me
wonder even more like what what does
this title exactly mean it doesn't just
mean you know Luke arrear the latter the
last remaining Jedi I just can't quite
put together what Luke means but I would
love to hear what you guys have to say
in the comment boxes because it changes
a lot of the title meaning for me
I didn't even already it wasn't sure
what I meant before but now it's even
it's mana really that's a good teaser
trailer because it's just making me want
to find out what the [ __ ] is going on
and it looks like that scene to me this
is my speculation could be wrong get
that shot with r2d2 looks like in the
shadow it's Luke Skywalker next to him
the fire and everything is that brief
moment in the force awakens where Luke
as handover r2d2 looks like was that
seem where I think Luke was given the
message to r2d2 it seems like that's the
scene we're gonna we're actually going
to see it all play out of what was
actually happening in that specific
scene if it looks like this is this this
will be the explanation of what was
going on there and even though it's a
short ass trailer it definitely feels
like this is going to be a lot darker
and I'm drawing this [ __ ] to it you know
as much as everyone's saying like the
force awakens is just a new hope redone
again I kind of feel like that was
intentional sort of like to mislead you
when they brought back the franchise you
know they do the force awakens which is
supposed to be like Oh reminiscent of a
new hope the making it seem familiar
making it feel like we know what
direction this is going down but then
with this one I think this is when
twists and turns and the real surprises
I don't think this is going to be just
Empire Strikes Back I feel like this is
when we're going to see that all that
setup from the force awakens is the way
the force awakens ends is not like a new
hope I don't think this is just going to
be a movie that has a similar beat sheet
to any of the previous Star Wars movies
I feel like this is when it's going to
get all the originality and their this
is when it's going to start taking a lot
of darker turns a lot crazier reveals oh
my god all in suits I can't I just
really love this trailer that it shows
you a lot but it also doesn't show you
anything the same types a lot of
theories are going to be coming out I
can't wait to hear what everyone has to
say
it just looks insanely huge your battles
in space look incredible the battles on
the island we still haven't seen
lightsaber battle in the trailer yet but
you know a shot with Rey running with a
lightsaber I little [ __ ] run oh man
uh
I know the force awakens felt like a new
hope for a lot of people I don't think
this is going to have the same beat
sheet as Empire Strikes Back but I could
see it being in this similar vein of
Empire Strikes Back where this is where
everything falls apart for the main
characters where everything goes just
significantly darker for everyone in the
end setting up for a great third
installment I love it I love it and the
cinematography looks even crazier thanks
for everyone telling me this is out my
brother was actually the first one to
tell me it was out but thank you hey I
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell